okay so this is the last video that I'm
doing in this series of the four basic
modes in Indian clubs three previous
videos will be posted in the description
below so today we're going to look at
split Time same
direction this mode differs slightly
from the other modes in the fact that my
arms aren't extended the whole
time as you can see here as my arms meet
in the middle I need to bend at my
elbows to allow them to cross if that
doesn't happen they end up hitting each
other
and Crossing like this it's possible to
do this and turn and go into a weave but
for now I won't be covering that in this
video so going back to our key points
your arms should be at opposite ends
apart from when they're cross in the
middle at this point you should leave
just enough space for your forearms to
pass each
other as you can see here both my arms
are rotating to my left keep checking
your position that your hands are
opposite ends top and bottom and left
and right
and that they cross and meet in the
middle this now is looking at going the
opposite direction rotating to my
right do exactly the same thing ensuring
that you're hitting all the key
points so with the clubs we'll do the
same thing but this time we need to
allow a bit more space for the clubs to
pass in the
middle arms want to be extended as they
sweep out the ends of the clubs should
always be facing opposite directions
even when they pass in the
middle once the movement starts to feel
comfortable try smoothing it
out and completing one
rotation if you find that everything's
in time then try doing it in one
continuous
motion and it should look something like
this so this is rotating to my left now
let's have a look at it going to my my
right start off the same in Shing you're
hitting all four key points and Crossing
in the
middle then again once you're happy with
this try to make the movement more fluid
and doing it
[Music]
continuously so now we'll have a look at
the Windmill the windmill is basically a
reel like covered in mode one but done
in Split time so instead of both clubs
together they actually split and they're
opposite ends you can achieve this by
speeding up your inside arm from same
time to split
time so to break this down you can see
here I'm doing a reel with my right hand
going
outwards then with my left hand I'm
doing a real go going
inwards I'm only demonstrating One
Direction here so the same will need to
be repeated on the other
side so putting them together if you
start with your arms out it should look
something like
this okay that's it for the four basic
modes if you have any questions or
comments please leave them in the
comments below also if you found this
useful please like And subscribe and
I'll upload some more
tutorials thanks for watching